[Música]
nós somos uns enormes projetos assim
vocês vocês não sentem frio
nós vivemos hoje a melhor época da
história da humanidade
neste debate do do oficial é natural
os ofensores da tecnologia
vamos dizer que não vou dizer que temos
vidas nas jornadas e tecnologia conector
natureza e fox
o dia todo em outras na história e criam
na outra época da história realmente
escolhem épocas como os agentes o
regimento e páginas da história e eu
vejo com alguma graça quem gostaria de
ter vivido na época da história é por
ser muito bom conquistar esta visão esta
visão de outras épocas da história
destes opositores à tecnologia e à
evolução acho que é uma visão demasiado
romântica e segmentada daquilo que foi a
nossa história não se esquecem
seguramente que a vida da grande maioria
da população não é seguramente como
aquela que é retratada nesta nesta
imagem mais de 95% da população vive em
condições que nós seríamos hoje
completamente uma grande e mesmo com os
produzidos daquela daquela fotografia eu
tenho dúvidas que vida pois assim tão
fantástica objetos pensando nos mais
produzidos todos realeza ser
reimplantado rainha do henrique 8o
talvez não
e o terceiro é o tempo médio reinado foi
6 anos e tendo em conta que a primeira
durou 24
imagino dentro das outras ainda na mesa
o primeiro é preciso ter 16 encontrar um
sucessor
10 10 16 filhos morreram antes dos 10
anos de idade
eu tenho dois filhos e não quero sequer
imaginar o que a dor para um filho
imaginem a falar das suas mais
pronunciadas na altura com acesso a
condições de higiene alimentação
conforto embora o crime é desprezado o
cheiro
infelizmente as dimensões outras épocas
a tecnologia não tem a capacidade de
acolher preservar e aplicar o cheiro de
outras alturas eu tenho certeza que eu
mudaria muito rapidamente vai acontecer
muito voltar atrás do passado uma
história na altura da colonização de
espanhóis na américa do sul sempre
cozinha que estava junto espanhóis tinha
um incenso licença queimar espanholas
chavão a realização de uma divindade e
por isso temos licença e não como as
respeitam a explicação é porque eles não
se importavam as escolhas
nós vivemos fato na melhor altura da
história
nunca na história tivemos níveis de
pobreza tão baixo
nunca tivemos em investir no irã e
trazia tão baixo e mesmo complementa
conflitos armados que estão muito na
ordem do dia a discussão mas não ser
direto instituição e cumpriu diz passos
são apenas aquelas curto espaço de tempo
que terminariam duas guerras mesmo nível
hoje em dia morrem mais pessoas por
suicídio do resultante do conflito
armado
está época mais pacífica da história da
humanidade e portanto é sinalizado
subjacente é voltar atrás na história é
mais ou menos como um norueguês um só é
com inglês e português dizer a ele onde
viver na venezuela e república
democrática do congo e ainda assim há
uns tempos atrás na história da
tecnologia java outras stoxx de
tecnologia que turva e tecnologia de
sensores setor de tecnologia
um exemplo é aumentar as pílulas como
complemento alimentar dos animais forma
industrializada ou agricultura do fogo
do fogo para aquecer e tecnologia tudo
isso acompanha o homem desde há muito
tempo queria e milhões
e muito desse crescimento foi alavancado
e é permitido permitido pela tecnologia
se não tivesse dia era impossível termos
101 milhões de pessoas na terra
um exemplo deste painel estamos aqui em
2011 voltar à época da revolução
industrial 50 anos voltar à comunhão
total com a natureza e voltar a exercer
dois corretores
o fantástico também mas saiba que uma
pessoa tem a sorte de que aquele amigo
que não recebeu então enfim nós nós
vivemos na mesma altura da história e
sempre vivemos de resultados e quando
essa tecnologia que tínhamos tanto tempo
esse tema agora por que tanta discussão
roteamento o tema tecnologia
neste momento a questão é porque nós
estamos a começar a viver a melhor
posição da história da humanidade
e tal como todas as outras grandes
produções
é uma função a sinergia porque não sonho
é agrícola
foi uma evolução tecnológica porque não
são industrial foi a evolução
tecnológica que combinou duas
tecnologias
a máquina a vapor e energia elétrica é
publicada a produção em massa que hoje
em dia nós vivemos uma revolução que
também combina duas tecnologias de forma
que o computador é uma solução de
conectividade e conectividade
nós já tomamos também a história os pó
as cidades que mais se desenvolveram
foram aquelas que mais abriram as trocas
com outros povos comerciais troca de
conhecimento daquela junta portas terem
muito rapidamente conectar todos os 7
mil milhões de pessoas da terra conectar
as pessoas com máquinas máquinas com
máquinas voltar a conectar máquinas com
as pessoas estão sempre fica a troca de
conhecimento de uma maneira
absolutamente extraordinária e que traz
algumas e dava risada porque elas não
esperam que os problemas não estão nem
estão demonstrados que é uma decisão
muito rápida exponencial falar no
comercial
nós falamos às vezes muitos elementos
que a informação ao acordo da humanidade
dobra todos os seis meses que o cabeça
após lançamento da obra todos os meses e
outros oito meses
estão a função inicial de 2 e nós temos
muita dificuldade em pensar em em mote
inicial
vou dar um exemplo se eu quero aqui
nesta folha de papel tem menos de 10%
milton sobre uma vez celebrar duas vezes
se eu tivesse fisicamente a capacidade
de dobrar 42 vezes equivalente à
distância entre a terra ea lua estão
inicial e é isso hein
e naturalmente tem interesse em tal e
preocupa muitas pessoas se elas já
estavam se lá com que isto vai dar esse
gráfico promete muito vocês já conhecem
que é a velocidade que algumas
tecnologias demoraram a se classificar e
por cima ficar entre 10 e 50 milhões de
clientes ou 50 milhões de dólares 75
anos 38 a tv 13.4 a internet 3g facebook
um ano e nove meses e mais recentemente
do pokémon go 1910 e estevão se dá com
que as coisas acontecem hoje portanto
aquelas que aquela conversa você não
estava sendo muito engraçada de nossa
voz e dizer a um filho e dizer eu há
quatro anos no mundo
nós combinamos expressiva diferencial
com estas cidades ficou muito ansiosas e
os grandes sábios que aumentam a
humanidade hoje eu diria que podem subir
em dois
os dois principais sites quiser ficar
mais principais o primeiro é já muito
falado que a orientação é um ser humano
em sua edição do homem pela máquina pelo
rolou
quando o facto nós utilizarmos
tecnologias tão poderosas vamos pôr em
risco a sobrevivência do planeta
postura que nos treinos eu sou como
norbert disse um otimista e bastante
nesta frase do instant action fantástica
que eu dizia eu sou um otimista nós
grande utilidade ser dita forma qualquer
lei só admita que ele tenha essa eu sou
do sporting tem e também que siga em
precious woods podem ser otimista
ele deve sair amanhã e se julga capaz de
transporte tem que ser especialmente
bons em matemática
estamos sempre a fazer contas mas enfim
eu sou otimista acho que a razão para o
otimismo que você me atacar os sites
nacionais jogos o primeiro primeiro tema
a humanização do ser humano eo medo que
temos que a próxima etapa da evolução do
homem saiu o homem da terra essas
máquinas estava um pouco turista mas
aqui um medo já assinado com isto muito
curto prazo que é daqui umas décadas 50%
dos nossos empregos 50%
nós temos hoje seguramente também não
estava muitas décadas atrás
se nós voltarmos atrás 150 voltarem
atrás até amanhã o tempo da pré
revolução industrial 80% dos empregos
nas cidades mais desenvolvidas na
agricultura hoje ele é menos de 2% ea
tecnologia sempre criou mais empregos
eu acho que destruiu nós temos muito
mais gente na terra temos muito mais
empresas da terra e trabalhamos -
segundo aspecto momento e sair quando
falamos dessa substituição falamos muito
do conceito de inteligência artificial
eu acho que é claramente um exagero ou
universidade não chamarmos inteligência
artificial ou queremos chamar estudos
mostram que há vários tipos de
inteligência é máquina consegue a vocês
sobre o homem numa dimensão muita gente
numa emissão de inteligência que é
lógico racional e nem todos os casos
lugar numa dimensão e dizer olha agora a
máquina do homem em todas as dimensões
parece claramente deseja é pra sempre
espaço para trabalho na atividade do
homem pra fazer aquilo que faço
francamente melhor do que a máquina e
acreditando muito mais numa imagem de
inteligência é aumentada para mostrá-lo
do pinto e é substituída ou inteligência
artificial
por exemplo eu tive há uns meses atrás
uma conferência que estava aberta prova
que é é entendido por muita gente como o
melhor jogador de xadrez da história da
humanidade e páginas eu nesta
conferência estava defendendo o conselho
dirigente aumentada e dizia os filmes na
década de 90 foi batido por um
computador
hoje em dia qualquer muito bom jogador
de xadrez é censurado por um computador
vencer em qualquer computador
este conceito chance aumentada com medo
tema de destruição do planeta
nós desde a década de 40
temos ao dispor da humanidade de uma
tecnologia póvoa muito rapidamente pôr
em causa não só a sobrevivência humana
como sobrevivência de muitas espécies
como a própria sobrevivência do planeta
há 70 anos que não usa e como disse
vivemos neste momento num momento mais
pacífica na história da humanidade
eu acho que temos que acreditar e ter um
pouco mais de bom senso
possa parecer ainda rotina do sistema da
do planeta
um exemplo mais positivo é o tema do
buraco do ozono começava em também foi
reportado no ano passado
o buraco ou área do buraco na camada de
ozônio foi mais pequena das últimas
décadas
isso foi também presidenciável em parte
por tecnologia por dois tecnologia
provar por tecnologia nos permite
desenvolver produtos menos nocivos à
camada do ozono e por lá e por outro
lado por aquela tecnologia tão tarde
criticada que os media edição as redes
sociais ajudaram a disseminar com a
sensibilizar e mobilizar ser humano a
atuar de forma contrária ao que foi
feito no passado
outro exemplo interessante da tecnologia
para o ambiente móvel é o transporte
mais utilizado na altura e riscos sérios
volta a viver o passado mas também acho
que hoje eu acho que amanhã vamos ter um
futuro em que o planeta é toda a gente
do planeta que terá eventos como esse
são fantásticos troca de idéias
vamos ser muito mais eficientes na
absorção dos ativos não ser muito menos
prudência trabalhos vão realizar muito
mais vamos trabalhar muito menos
e vamos viver melhor
vamos viver mais tempo vamos ter que ver
como estão mais tempo então não acho que
seria um contra senso
nós tivemos mais tempo para ter uma vida
pior
certo o jonas não me perdoo mas o
internato caminho
[Aplausos]